cette année on vous a préparé plusieurs
reportages sur le thème du bien-être
animal et on commence aujourd'hui en
s'intéressant au sort des petits veaux
dans le secteur laitier la recherche
dans ce domaine a fait beaucoup de
progrès au cours des dernières années
pour en discuter je me suis entretenu
avec une professeur de l'université de
la colombie britannique
car de gros changements sont peut-être à
l'horizon
[Musique]
voici un petit brin de futures sur
quatre pattes chancelante des génisses
âgé de quelques mois une fois adulte
elles auront à leur tour un veau et
rejoindront le troupeau laitier
ces animaux marina von kaiser link les
étudie depuis plus de 30 ans
cette idée de faire de la recherche pour
améliorer la vie des animaux me
fascinait vraiment
[Musique]
ce qui me motive c'est de trouver des
manières d'améliorer le bien-être animal
qui feront aussi la sphère des fermiers
cette chercheuse fait partie d'un groupe
de scientifiques qui révolutionne
certaines pratiques de l'industrie
laitière
leurs solutions sont parfois tout simple
comme de laisser tester les vaut tous
les choix esthétiques traditionnellement
on enseignait aux veaux à boire dans un
seau ils n'avaient pas accès à une
cantine
ce sont des mammifères et le fait de tt
est un comportement inné chez eux sac
donc nous avons vraiment mis de l'avant
l'idée que les nourrir avec une tétine
c'est la meilleure façon de faire d'où
l'importance de faire de la recherche
pour guider les agriculteurs et une au
canada un très grand nombre de
producteurs aujourd'hui et c'est en
partie parce qu'ils ont eux-mêmes
financer notre recherche se servent de
tétines pour nourrir leurs veaux il leur
donne aussi beaucoup plus de lait et
leurs veaux ne sont plus affamés les
études de votre équipe marina ont mené à
des changements concrets notamment dans
la quantité de lait qu'on donne aux
petits veaux par les knicks on ne leur
donnait que 4 litres de lait par jour
les veaux qui tètent leurs mères peuvent
boire de 10 à 15 litres par jour alors
il était à famille
si on leur donnait si peu de lait c'est
entre autres parce que ça coûte cher
mais aussi parce qu'on croyait que moins
de lait permettrait un meilleur contrôle
de problèmes comme la diaries
quand on lui donne du lait à volonté un
veau peut prendre un kilo par jour
quand il prend plus de poids il a moins
tendance à tomber malade c'est positif
et si donner plus de lait peut sembler
une dépense c'est en fait un
investissement
les petites génisses qui ont reçu plus
de l'est au début de leur vie
deviendront plus tard plus productive
des collègues israéliens et américains
ont publié des données compilées sur le
long terme tant que révèle que les
vaches témoignent de leur reconnaissance
en produisant beaucoup plus de lait
ces nouvelles connaissances ont entraîné
une révision du code des bonnes
pratiques dans le secteur laitier le
canada a d'ailleurs été l'un des
premiers pays à recommander de doubler
la quantité de lait donnés aux veaux et
les changements ne s'arrêtent pas là en
obtenant andrée watters lorsqu'ils sont
repus les veaux non plus tendance à
téter tout ce qu'ils trouvent
ça c'est un signe qu'ils ont faim et
s'ils ne font plus ça on peut alors les
loger en groupe ce qui est pour eux
beaucoup plus naturelle
[Musique]
jusqu'à récemment les enclos individuels
comme les ruches étaient fortement
recommandée en production laitière on
croyait ainsi éviter la transmission des
maladies mais la science a démontré que
si l'enclos est propre et bien ventilé
les veaux ne seront pas plus malades
s'ils sont regroupés et quand ils n'ont
pas de contact avec leurs semblables
dans les premières semaines de vie
marina et ses collègues ont démontré que
ces animaux grégaires développe un
déficit cognitif ils apprennent moins
vite sont moins capables de s'adapter
aux changements
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quand les veaux sont élevés par deux ou
en groupe ils sont beaucoup plus calmes
moins craintif pour les fermiers c'est
positif
vivant à
des animaux craintif peuvent se blesser
ils sont plus difficiles à attraper
parce qu'ils paniquent
et s'il faut les déplacer
c'est beaucoup plus simple s'ils sont
plus calmes
au fil des ans de nombreux producteurs
ont adopté ces façons de faire mais
marina von kaiser link sans que les
défis à venir seront d'une autre nature
[Musique]
les producteurs laitiers parlait
autrefois de confort
de la quantité de litière nécessaire
pour les vagues
ce genre de choses là aujourd'hui les
enjeux sont plus denses plus complexe
la société s'invite dans le débat avec
ses étudiants elle en a eu un exemple
révélateur en 2014 dans l'industrie
laitière et en agriculture en général on
croit fermement que si on éduque le
public
si je vous ai duc vous allez me faire
confiance le oui et vous allez acheter
mes produits
on a décidé de mettre cette hypothèse à
l'épreuve
[Musique]
lors d'une journée portes ouvertes à la
ferme expérimentale de l'université
cinquante visiteurs qui ne venaient pas
du milieu agricole se sont vu soumettre
cinq questions on aura posé cinq
questions très simples du genre
une vache laitière doit elle avoir un
veau pour produire du lait
sur 50 personnes seulement 28 ont
répondu correctement donc le public en
général connais très peu la production
laitière et les autres questions étaient
tout aussi facile pour quiconque
travaille dans l'industrie laitière moi
l'une d'elles était est ce que les
vaches en colombie britannique
on taxait au pâturage
la plupart des gens qui ne sont pas dans
l'industrie en cette vision d'une vache
laitière au chant donc évidemment ils
ont répondu oui
mais la réalité c'est que la majorité
des vaches ne verront jamais un bras en
moyenne les participants obtiennent
trois bonnes réponses sur cinq pendant
l'heure qui suit ils prennent part à une
visite guidée de la ferme école un
endroit où les meilleures pratiques de
l'industrie sont mises de l'avant
à la fin de la visite nous leur avons
soumis les mêmes questions ils ont
obtenu quatre bonnes réponses sur cinq
ce we had hadj qaïda donc nous les
avions éduquer la majorité des gens
trouvaient que les vaches on avait eu
une belle vie ils étaient enchantés des
soins que les animaux recevait à la
ferme ils étaient renversées de voir à
quel point les vaches et mais leur
nourriture ça c'était l'aspect positif
mais ils ont été absolument choquée
d'apprendre qu'on sépare et les veaux à
la naissance et que les vaches n'avaient
pas accès aux pâturages
images qu'ils avaient en tête ne
correspondait pas à ce qu'ils ont vu
conférencier renommé on la voit ici en
2019 s'adressant à des vétérinaires à
saint-hyacinthe marina livre un message
qui est brun certaines certitudes
[Musique]
dans l'industrie laitière la
quasi-totalité des veaux sont séparés de
leur mère moins de 24 heures après leur
naissance
et pourquoi historiquement on a séparé
les vaches et les veaux les séparer ça
tombe sous le sens pour un producteur
laitier
parce que son salaire vient du lait
qu'il vend
des raisons de santé aussi longtemps
justifié la séparation les veaux
naissent avec un système immunitaire
très faible et on pensait qu'on pourrait
mieux les superviser s'ils étaient
séparés de leur mère on croyait aussi
que le veau serait plus en santé qu'il y
aurait moins de mortalités si on les
sépare est
la comparaison entre l'industrie
laitière et l'industrie bovine saveur à
ce sujet éclairante chez les bovins de
boucherie on ne vend pas le lait mais
plutôt la viande les petits veaux reste
donc avec leur mère très souvent à
l'extérieur et sont sevrés à six mois
dans le secteur laitier ils le sont
beaucoup plus tôt à deux mois environ il
cesse de boire du lait
le taux de mortalité des veaux dans
l'industrie bovine et de 6% dans
l'industrie laitière c'est plus du
double
c'est extrêmement élevé mon père qui
était éleveur bovin aurait fait faillite
avec des chiffres pareils donc je pense
qu'il ya beaucoup de travail à faire
pour améliorer la santé des veaux
laitiers
mais qu'en est il de la santé des vaches
elles mêmes après la séparation au coût
de vache tombe malade après avoir mis
bas c'est aussi entre 25 et 35%
il y à de grandes variations d'une ferme
à l'autre mais c'est la moyenne et on
sait qu'une vache malade produit moins
de lait la science a démontré que de
garder le veau avec la mère peut
contribuer à réduire l'incidence de
certaines maladies comme la mammite une
inflammation des mamelles qui coûte très
cher aux producteurs laitiers
normalement entre les vaches deux fois
par jour
mais le veau surtout dans les trois
quatre premières semaines va téter sa
mère six huit dix fois par jour il me
faudrait donc une infection a beaucoup
moins le temps de s'installer celui ci
et on voit un effet protecteur très
marqué
l'équipe de marina s'intéresse aussi à
la santé globale de la vache après la
mise bas incluant son état émotionnel
on lui impose toutes sortes de choses
dès qu'elles veulent on lui enlève son
petit si c'est son premier elle doit
tout de suite s'adapter aux robots de
traite par exemple
ça fait beaucoup de stress
et de nouveautés en même temps
et c'est sans parler de l'instinct
maternel qu'on ne laisse pas s'exprimer
en lui retirant son veau
la chercheuse se demande donc si
certaines vaches ne souffriraient pas de
dépression post partum un champ d'étude
qui en est à ses premiers balbutiements
dans le secteur laitier oil man une
façon d'étudier la dépression on essaie
de prendre des rates en gestation
de les laisser mettre bas et de le
retirer ensuite leur bébé
dans le monde des animaux de laboratoire
ce modèle est largement reconnu pour
étudier la dépression d'une certaine
façon c'est ce qu'ont fait chaque jour
avec les vaches ans
[Musique]
même si elle voulait aujourd'hui guidé
les producteurs laitiers qui souhaite
garder les veaux avec leur mère beaucoup
de questions restent en suspens combien
de temps que les garder ensemble comment
adapter le bâtiment comment faire un
sevrage qui ne causera pas plus de
stress
[Musique]
mais
ce que je dis aux agriculteurs
si ça va prendre du courage mais je
crois qu'il faut commencer à en parler
je suis convaincu que la population en
général aiment les fermiers et veut leur
faire confiance
personne ne s'attend à ce que tout
change du jour au lendemain mais les
gens s'attendent à ce qu'ils essaient
chaque jour de s'améliorer
[Musique]